fifty Shades freed in this is the third
in the trilogy you are married now yes
and you you've what's interesting is
that you're married now and it seems to
me like your characters are having more
sex than they did when they were single
so let's funny yeah that's funny
I mean I've suspended my disbelief for
Star Trek and Star Wars and now it's
poetic license it's a movie it's you
know so far from reality as we know it I
guess where your wife can get enough of
you I think it's sweet though it's
encouraging that they're having so much
sex yes it's fantastic it's a great
advertisement for getting marries really
you're like oh my god those two people
it's incredible you know so yeah it's
just I can't see it with my wife should
be like what the hell's wrong with you
we have a did you get notes then on you
know I mean sexy notes sexy notes do
they give you sexy notes does the
director come up to you and give you
sexy notes um I think there's been
attempts about you know it's it's a
tricky that's a tricky conversation you
know um I feel like there's times where
maybe I think the coda would be quicker
to give me a note than the director how
do tell you yeah in terms of like
sometimes you know maybe are in the
first movie I guess there's a sexy way
to take off a girl's underwear mm-hmm
but you know that isn't just like this
is when you're pranking someone
[Laughter]
she told you yeah times it's you know
that's it sort of needs most yes and but
no there is a more delicate and sensual
way to do it which is which is a thumbs
into the side and then and then you sort
of shimmy it down I'm gonna combine that
with this face Donald Trump nice and
year right now there's a minute I'll
make this 0 voice we have a clip here
from Fifty Shades freed anything we need
to know for this no I can't quite
remember what it is alright
I bet it's sexy yeah it looks actually
big great YouTube just talking about
landscaping let's take a look
[Music]
welcome home a stage Christian where is
everybody else where
I never mad at me Tara
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and II you can weigh on this if I walked
up behind my wife and put a blindfold on
her she would stab me to death yeah she
returned looked me in the eye and say
what is wrong
you